first let me introduce myself I'm Herman
Herman I'm the director of the National
go buttocks engineering center which is
where you are right now okay I like to
welcome all of you here it's nice to
have everybody here we are honored today
to have the US Secretary of
Transportation Anthony Foxx here with us
we are so very happy to have console
mundane gilman Councilwoman Dubois gross
lease piece back from Senator Casey
office and Catalan King from senator
Toomey office here with us as well okay
we are very excited to have secretary
Foxx chose Carnegie Mellon for this
event it gives us an excellent
opportunity to showcase some of the
technology that we've been working the
transportation area in addition to the
autonomous car here that shown on the
background and email and also develop
any technology that increase the
efficiency and safety in the
transportation area such as the smart
app like or the intelligent traffic
light control in fact some of this
research is funded directly by the OT so
thank you ok without much further ado
let me introduce the next speaker Zoe
Levinson sees a graduate student in the
Heinz collates and pushing a clean
transportation
good afternoon my name is Zoe Levinson
and like previous stated I'm this year's
women and transportation fellow from
Carnegie Mellon's tisa University
transportation center as well I'm also
pursuing my masters and information
systems management at CMU's Heinz
college I have the pleasure today to
introduce US Department of
Transportation Secretary Anthony Foxx
but first I'd like to thank the
secretary for spending time with fellow
students to discuss the future of
Transportation and how our
interdisciplinary skills can shape the
system that serves future mobility needs
Anthony Foxx became the 17th United
States Secretary of Transportation in
July of 2013 his primary goal is to
ensure that America maintains the safest
and most efficient transportation system
in the world secretary Foxx joined the
US Department of Transportation after
serving as mayor of Charlotte North
Carolina from 2009 to 2013 during that
time he made efficient and innovative
transportation investments which
centerpiece of Charlotte's job creation
and economic recovery efforts as a
member of City Council he chaired the
Transportation Committee as well as the
Mecklenburg Union Metropolitan Planning
Organization secretary Foxx has served
as an attorney in private practice as
well as held distinguished positions
with the u.s. Sixth Circuit Court of
Appeals and the Department of Justice he
received a law degree from New York
University's School of Law and his
bachelor's degree in history from
Davidson College as population continues
to shift in metropolitan areas and our
cities are rapidly evolving through new
technologies we look forward to
secretary Fox's experience and emphasis
on innovation to guide us in developing
a 21st century mobility vision and
transportation system with that we
welcome secretary Foxx
Zoey thank you so much for that
wonderful introduction I've had a great
great visit here at Carnegie Mellon
today and I do want to thank not only
you Zoe but also dr. Harmon Harmon the
director of this incredible robotics
engineering center president subra
Suresh of the entire university staying
calm well the executive director of
traffic 21 the many students and faculty
who've joined us today as well as city
councilman Dan Gilman who's also here
today where is Dan Gilman thank you just
want to say hello to you sir I've had an
opportunity today to see some amazing
research some amazing technology and
some amazing minds that are wrapping
their heads around the transportation
challenges in the US over the 21st
century and I guess the way to start the
brief remarks I have today is to say
that when we think about the way
transportation has evolved in human
history think about the transition from
mankind simply walking to using
machinery to move that was controlled by
the human being which is where we've
spent most of our time in transportation
since those days when a man and woman
were just walking and now we're entering
into a phase where the technology is
becoming much smarter much more capable
of taking on tasks that human beings had
previously taken on all the way to the
possibility of driverless vehicles this
is a watershed moment in transportation
and part of the challenge we have as an
agency and as a society is building the
foundation for these technologies to
take root I'm here today not only to
celebrate the fact that us do tease
investments in the
UTC here in Carnegie Mellon coupled with
the incredible partnerships public and
private across the disciplines within
this university with groups like traffic
21 and tea set that we are on the cusp
of seeing this transition occur and
working together we will build the kind
of regulatory framework that assures
that it gets integrated into the
marketplace safely one of the things
it's also interesting about being here
today coming out of Washington DC which
some people describe as 1 square miles
surrounded by reality is that you are
clearly focused on the future that's
what you're doing every single day here
and if I'm doing my job as Secretary of
Transportation I'm also focused on the
future you know we just did a study that
we call beyond traffic it looks 30 years
out to the US is transportation
challenges and we see incredible
incredible opportunity but also
incredible challenges in front of us we
talk about a population that's growing
by 70 million people by 2045 we talk
about the concentration of many of those
people into our region's our mega
regions places that are highly populated
already congested already constrained
when we look at the fact that we're
going to need to move forty-five percent
more Freight over the 30 year period
when we think about the fact that our
climate and disruptive weather patterns
are playing a role in disrupting our
infrastructure and we even have airports
that are above water level today that
could be below water level within this
30 year period or by the end of the
century we also think about the fat
that technology's playing an incredible
role in changing how we even think about
movement 3d printing for example has the
potential to radically change
distribution systems in this country
when it comes to moving goods around the
idea that you can be in one part of the
world and push a button and a product
can be produced by a printer and move
quickly to its ultimate location that is
a radical change in the way we've
thought about moving goods or unmanned
aircraft that have the promise to change
the way products are distributed
obviously we have challenges with making
sure we safely integrate those vehicles
into the air space but that is another
part of the future and then we also have
to think about the ways in which our
transportation system governance occurs
you know it would be one thing if we had
one consolidated transportation unit
that could make decisions across the
whole system but just think about the
fact that our highways are basically
state-managed our transit systems are
basically local manage our freight rail
systems are mostly private our federal
aviation system is mostly federal and so
as we look at how to integrate a
seamless transportation network that
incorporates these incredible
innovations it's going to take a lot of
teamwork and it's going to take a lot of
focus on the part of private and public
universities philanthropy all of us
working together to make sure we not
only make the right systems available
but that we have the right decision
making processes in place so I'm going
to tell you how incredible it is to come
here and to see a Cadillac that has all
of this cool technology on it I don't
think they felt comfortable letting me
ride around in it because I made a try
to drive it myself and may not have
stopped on the way out I don't know
traffic signals that adjusts to traffic
that are smart enough to know without
having to be told by some central
command center that there's a pile up
and that they can move the traffic
faster by going green on them some cool
developments as part of vehicle to
vehicle technology which we are very
bullish about at the US Department of
Transportation and believe frankly that
the future or vehicle to vehicle
technology is one that will enhance
safety because when technology can see
parts of the roadway that a human being
can't and can make use of it to avoid a
collision we ought to be able to adapt
that technology and make good use of it
so as a department we are extremely
bullish on the types of activities that
you're doing and I do want to say one
other point it came up in the
conversation I had with some of the
students brilliant students by the way
one of the questions was you know how do
we take a more lean in position as an
agency with this new technology and let
me let me just conclude by making this
at this point I've heard many observers
note that the rate of technological
change just in general across the world
is increasing you know you might have
gotten one big innovation that might
have happened once every 100 years in
previous errors or maybe once every 50
years more recently but we're now seeing
just incredible changes happening within
two or three years and in transportation
as a sector we tend to lag behind most
of the other sectors in terms of
integrating that technology and what I
want to tell you is is that we at USDOT
are committed to moving more rapidly and
taking a more lenient position on
technology to make sure that we can
assure ourselves that it's safe but to
also make sure that it reaches into the
market
place as quickly as is practicable so
we're going to continue working to build
systems and processes and to use data
and all kinds of innovative ways to
ensure that we're moving technology into
the marketplace as quickly as possible
again recognizing that our first
priority our first job is to make sure
it's moving in safely and so with that I
want to thank you all very much for
having us here we do have copies of our
summaries of our beyond traffic survey
we are also looking forward to the input
of many stakeholders in to what our 30
year outlook says and I invite you to go
to do t gov / beyond traffic and to
submit your comments there's a lot of
knowledge in this room and a lot of
input that would be very valuable for us
to receive before a final report comes
out with that thank you very much and I
look forward to a couple of questions